this video is brought to you by
manscapes.com
the global brand for men's grooming and
hygiene products hey 42 here we all love
a good party music drinks presents games
cake
the unraveling of a 4 000 year old
mummified corpse
is there any better way to spend a
saturday night
okay so maybe the mummified corpses
aren't quite so popular these days
but for a while back in victorian
england a party wasn't a party unless an
irreplaceable egyptian artifact was
being desecrated in the name of
entertainment
because as weird as it may sound
mummy unwrapping parties were once all
the rage but what exactly caused 19th
century brits to think that mummified
corpses were the season's must-have
accessory well you might be surprised to
find out it was a little known frenchman
by the name of napoleon bonaparte who
was to blame
well sort of
as you'll know i've been a huge fan of
manscaped for some time now they offered
the best tools and solutions for the big
free odor zones your body butt and balls
and you can now get the ultimate
manscaped experience when you purchase
their new performance package 4.0 bundle
so firstly you can start grooming in the
shower with their new lawnmower 4.0
waterproof cordless trimmer including
replaceable ceramic blades with skin
safe technology so it makes it super
easy to tackle your green grooming with
confidence and without any mess
then after your shower be sure to treat
yourself by applying the manscaped crop
preserver ball deodorant it's a quick
absorbing clear drying moisturizing
lotion for all-day protection and for a
quick midday refresher be sure to pack
your crop reviver ball toner spray with
its cooling antivirus and
anti-inflammatory properties
but manscaped is so much more than a
ball trimmer company in fact their new
performance package 4.0 bundle now
includes their new weed whacker nose and
ear hair trimmer this thing is an
absolute game changer it makes tackling
those pesky nose hairs super easy
for a limited time you can also get not
one but two free gifts with your
performance package 4.0 bundle the shed
travel bag
and the manscaped anti-chafing
high-performance boxer briefs all you
need to do is head to manscapes.com
forward slash 42 today to get 20 off
free international shipping plus two
free gifts
your balls and your body will thank you
when napoleon and his troops arrived in
the egyptian city of alexandria in 1798.
napoleon didn't just have war on his
mind as well as the small matter of
conquering egypt in order to disrupt
trade routes between britain and india
napoleon also fancied himself
as a bit of a pharaoh fanboy
alongside his 35 000 soldiers he'd
brought with him 167 scholars artists
and scientists whose sole purpose it was
to find and document the vast array of
ancient artifacts hieroglyphics temples
and tombs belonging to the mysterious
civilization that had once inhabited the
banks of the river now
on napoleon's orders these findings were
compiled and published in a book called
the description of egypt
apparently napoleon wasn't big on catchy
titles
during the three-year egyptian campaign
as this little jaunt in north africa
would come to be known napoleon's troops
would make a groundbreaking discovery
that would completely transform our
understanding of ancient egypt
while strengthening the foundations of
fort julian on the west banks of denial
they accidentally stumbled upon one of
the most important archaeological finds
of all time
the rosetta stone
this irregular shaped hulking mass of
granite
might not have looked all that exciting
but it contained the key to finally
understanding ancient egyptian
hieroglyphics which for years had made
about as much sense as pineapple on
pizza seriously fruit on pizza
what makes the rosetta stone so special
is that it was carved with the same
inscription three times in three
different languages two ancient egyptian
languages hieroglyphics and demotic and
ancient greek although egyptian
hieroglyphics had yet to be deciphered
ancient greek was still understood by
some scholars and so by comparing one
with the other the foundations for
understanding all those cool
inscriptions of snakes birds and scarab
beetles had finally been laid
the discovery of the rosetta stone and
the publication of the description of
egypt made ancient egypt more accessible
than ever before and pretty soon the
general public were obsessed with this
fascinating period in human history
egyptomania was born
but as its popularity rose people became
a bit bored of just looking at
illustrations and reading boring words
they wanted to see egypt's incredible
relics with their own eyes
eager to cash in on the fad museums and
collectors began clambering over one
another to ransack the wealth of
egyptian artifacts that had been lying
undisturbed beneath the sands of egypt
for thousands of years
unfortunately for the museums the
ancient egyptians had hidden away many
of these treasures deep below the ground
within hard to reach burial chambers
and to add insult to injury many of the
impressive statues and obelisks that
were just sitting there enticingly above
ground were large and cumbersome making
them extremely difficult to steal i mean
recover for scientific purposes
it's almost as if the ancient egyptians
didn't want their prized relics moved
from their final resting places solving
this problem was going to require
someone with a significant amount of
skill and expertise
enter giovanni belzoni or
the great belzoni as he was known the
great belzoni cv was a little varied to
say the least at one point or another
he'd worked as a barber an engineer an
explorer a circus strong man and he'd
even spent time as a trainee monk but it
was his work as an archaeologist that
he's best remembered for today belzoni
was a beast of a man six foot seven
inches tall and built like a brick
house
in 1815 the italian giant traveled to
egypt where he intended to sell
engineering equipment to muhammad ali
not that one the ottoman ruler muhammad
ali of egypt and the sudan but belzoni's
bid to impress the ruler with his
state-of-the-art hydraulic water raising
machine didn't go down as well as he'd
hoped and he soon found himself without
work thousands of miles from home
fortunately for belzoni a group of
archaeologists were in the area having a
spot of bother trying to dig out a
colossal granite statue of ramesses ii a
task which napoleon's men had attempted
and failed to complete some years before
using his expertise in engineering and
hydraulics and with a tiny bit of help
from hundreds of local workers
belzoni not only succeeded in extracting
the statue but also transporting it
along the nile to alexandria
from there it would make its way to
london to be proudly displayed in the
british museum where it remains to this
day
belzoni had found his calling he began
working tirelessly sending a steady
stream of ancient relics to overseas
museums and collectors becoming a kind
of indiana jones of his day he
discovered the tomb of seti in the
valley of kings he located the entrance
to the temple of rameses ii
and was the first person in modern times
to penetrate the second largest of the
great pyramids of giza the pyramid of
carvery belzoni eventually traveled to
london with a bounty of riches including
amongst many other things a selection of
mummified corpses
there he enlisted the help of
distinguished surgeon thomas pettigrew
to find out just what lurked beneath
those grubby old bandages
pedigree was the perfect man for the job
he'd had a lifelong obsession with human
anatomy and he'd been performing illegal
autopsies in his teenage years before
becoming a surgeon's apprentice when he
was just 16. more importantly he also
had a keen interest in antiquities if
anyone was up for the task of unwrapping
a mummified corpse it was him
at first these mummy unwrappings or
unrollings as they were known were
performed in the name of research but
word soon spread that someone was
investigating mummies arguably the most
intriguing of all ancient egyptian
artifacts
and london's elite began requesting that
petty crew hosts these macabre
spectacles in the privacy of their own
homes for the purposes of entertainment
although pettigrew wasn't the first to
unwrap a mummy in the name of either
business or pleasure he is widely
regarded as the first to turn it into a
full-on performance
he understood that the majority of
people attending weren't there to hear
about scientific theories regarding the
mummification process or to find out
about the history of ancient egypt they
were there to uggle a dead body that had
been buried thousands of years ago by a
culture so vastly different to the one
they knew in victorian england that it
might as well have come from a different
planet
pessi grew and his mummy on rolling
passes always followed a set format
the guests would gather around the table
where the mummy would be presented
surrounded by egyptian symbols and
funerary hieroglyphics pettigrew would
begin by giving a short lecture about
the mummy that was about to be unwrapped
including a warning that the condition
of the corpse could not be guaranteed
and those with weak stomachs should
probably leave the room
he would then begin removing the mummy's
wrappings layer by layer until the
embalmed corpse was revealed as each
layer was revealed jewelry amulets and
ornaments were often found and handed
around the audience for closer
inspection it was a bit like a giant
pinata for adults
once the corpse was revealed pettigrew
would soar open the skull to show how
the brain had been removed as part of
the mummification process
occasionally the mummy would be hoisted
onto its feet as though it had risen
from the dead much to the delight of the
audience
finally pieces of bandages were cut up
and handed out as gruesome keepsakes
then london's finest would retire into
the night most likely secretly hoping
they hadn't been cursed by an ancient
egyptian pharaoh
attitude of the time meant people gave
little consideration to the religious
beliefs of the deceased and believe it
or not pettigrew's mummy unwrapping
parties were some of the least egregious
desecrations perpetrated against ancient
egyptians dead
there are accounts of mummies being
burnt and used as locomotive fuel or
being ground down to make a unique shade
of paint known as mummy brown you can
still buy mummy brown paint today by the
way but you'll be relieved to hear it no
longer contains actual dead people
if you've been watching the channel for
a while you'll also know it was once
widely believed that ingesting ground-up
mummies had a wide range of health
benefits people back then weren't only
interested in making use of human
corpses either in 1890 almost 20 tons of
ancient mummified cats were crushed and
used as fertilizer as the 19th century
drew to an end so did the obsession with
ancient egypt and eventually mummy
unwrapping parties began to fall out of
favor
you'd like to think that it was because
people realized just how disrespectful
it was to or brood a dead body from its
resting place send it to another part of
the world thousands of miles away and
then unwrap it during a particularly
disturbing game of pastor parcel
and although some people were beginning
to question the morality of playing
around of ancient corpses
the main reason mummy unwrapping parties
fell out of favor was that the novelty
value wore off fairly quickly
wealthy victorians soon realized that
once you'd seen one mummy you'd seen
them all and so they began to turn their
attention back to more wholesome
pastimes such as taxidermy seances and
posing for photos of dead bodies
our ancestors were weird weren't they
it's impossible to know for certain just
how many mummies were taken from egypt
during the egyptomania craze
mostly because nobody knows how many
there were to begin with
some historians estimate that as many as
70 million bodies may have been
mummified during the 3 000 years the
practice was popular in ancient egypt
meaning the ancient egyptian afterlife
should have about the same population as
the united kingdom although i imagine
the weather's a bit nicer thomas
pettigrew would go on to become the vice
president of the british archaeological
association where he continued his
studies into ancient egypt for much of
his life he was even given a chance to
put his knowledge of the mummification
process into practice when the 10th duke
of hamilton personally requested that
petty groom mummify him after the duke
had died of course
it was an opportunity pessi grew simply
couldn't pass up and the duke's
mummified body was eventually placed in
a genuine egyptian sarcophagus and laid
to rest in scotland i imagine that's
really going to confuse a team of
archaeologists in about a thousand years
time these days the idea of desecrating
a human body in the name of
entertainment would horrify most people
unless of course you're a serial killer
then you'd probably find the thought
quite appealing today ancient human
remains are treated with the utmost
respect and modern archaeological
techniques aim to be as non-intrusive as
possible
ct scans and dna analysis can tell us
about the deceased's diet lifestyle
profession and even how they died whilst
respectfully leaving their corpse intact
whilst egyptomania isn't quite as
virulent as it once was the impact
ancient egypt has had on the modern
world can't be overstated
we see its influence in architecture
movies novels fashion and art
every year millions of tourists travel
to egypt to gaze upon the great pyramids
marvel at the sphinx and explore the
awe-inspiring temples that were left
behind by the ancient egyptians
thankfully these days if you do visit
this remarkable country you're more
likely to return home with an i love
egypt fridge magnet than the mummified
remains of a long dead pharaoh
thanks for watching
good news you can now pre-order my new
book bread and circuses what did the
romans ever do for us
it's a wild and witty journey for a
thousand years of unexpected roman
history
told in a refreshing way and packed full
of incredible and unbelievable stories
copies are selling out fast so pre-order
yours today to lock it in
thank you